et on va plus loin avec Z Limam
directeur de la rédaction d'Afrique
magazine bonjour Ziad bonsoir Afrique
Magazine dont le numéro d'octobre titre
sur le Qatar face au but celui de la
Coupe du Monde bien sûr et puis
également on le voit l'Afrique au cœur
de la bataille du gaz les deux sujets
sont liés exactement
on va en parler évidemment dans un
instant Bruno Darroux face à vous
chroniqueur international ici même à
France 24 bonjour Bruno bonjour Raphaël
l'Amérique va-t-elle se retourner contre
l'Arabie Saoudite ce serait un virage
stratégique majeur c'est en tout cas ce
que laisse entendre Joe Biden tant
Washington s’estime trahi par la baisse
des quotas de production décidée la
semaine dernière par les pays
producteurs de pétrole dont l'Arabie
Saoudite est la Russie une décision qui
en renchérissant les cours du brut sert
d'ailleurs les intérêts de Moscou c'est
là tout le problème pour Joe Biden
écoutez-le hier sur CNN
quand la Chambre des Représentants et le
Sénat seront de retour il y aura des
conséquences pour ce que l'Arabie
saoudite a fait avec la Russie
je ne vais pas détailler ce que j'ai en
tête mais il y aura des conséquences
il y aura des conséquences ce que la
Maison Blanche en tête Bruno ce sont les
livraisons d'armariales oui absolument
et apparemment il y a une résolution
proposait déjà par certains congrès
semaines pour en fait punir donc
l'Arabie Saoudite d'être allé dans un
sens contraire à celui que souhaitait
les États-Unis concernant le niveau de
de pétrole dans le monde puisque Joe
Biden souhaitait que l'Arabie Saoudite
ouvre les vans c'est pour ça qu'il est
il avait fait le chemin non pas de
Cannes au sol Jedi au mois de juillet ça
lui avait coûté et il pensait que ça
allait dans le bon sens et puis là
patatra
MBS a pris la décision inverse donc
fureur colère quand même de Joe Biden
c'est ça qui est à l'origine de cette
colère donc effectivement sanction et
potentiellement donc un arrêt des
exportations d'armes américaines vers
l’arabie Saoudite bon après il va
falloir comment ça se passe concrètement
alors Joe Biden n'a pas l'a pas évoqué
il est resté il est resté assez flou
enfin juste un chiffre les exportations
d'armes vers l'Arabie Saoudite ça
représente près du quart des
exportations américaines d'armes
américaines dans le monde donc est-ce
que les Américains sont prêts à renoncer
à cette manif financière à voir ça
aurait un des conséquences d'après vous
il y a d'un coup de froid dans les
relations americano saoudienne ça peut
se rendre jusqu'à quel point le problème
c'est de qualifier c'est un coup de
froid est-ce que c'est un virage est-ce
que c'est un changement historique
est-ce que c'est
c'est on avait tellement l'habitude que
les pays du golf et l'Arabie Saoudite
soient totalement alignés sur les
positions américaines et on voit bien
dans cette histoire les éléments de ce
monde nouveau qui est en train de naître
avec des puissances intermédiaires qui
essayent de jouer leur carte qui ont
plus de liberté finalement de manœuvre
qu'auparavant on bien à quel point les
pays du Golfe ont une relation avec la
Russie qui est différente parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de de du principe premier
ministre MBS mais il y a eu le voyage
assez incroyable quand même du chef de
l'état des états des Émirats arabes unis
à Moscou qui à mon avis est presque
aussi parlant c'est-à-dire on voit bien
que c'est des pays qui ont une relation
à la Russie qui est plus qui est plus
complexe donc à mon avis il y a deux
choses il y a d'une part cette relation
plus complexe bon après il y a les les
les j'allais dire les caricatures Dubaï
ville russe avec tout l'argent de la
Russie qui vient s'installer mais ça
donne quand même des éléments de cette
complexité et la deuxième chose c'est
que sur l'affaire saoudienne il y a un
véritable bras de fer sur la question
pétrolière parce que quand nous on a
évoqué en Europe et aux États-Unis de
mettre un cap sur les prix du pétrole
c'est une attaque directe sur les
producteurs de pétrole de l'OPE mais on
parle l'Arabie sadisme ça peut être
l'Algérie ça peut être d'autres gens
donc ça je pense qu'avec une arme
anti-rus est vécu comme une l'ensemble
des producteur par tous les producteurs
comme une commune anti producteur pays
producteurs et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'il y a aussi en Arabie Saoudite en
tous les cas avec le prince héritier
Premier ministre pour se couvrir en cas
de voyage à l'étranger il y a quand même
cette vision d'une Arabie Saoudite
différente puissante
on construit des villes nouvelles on a
un espèce d'humbrice quand même qui
mériterait un petit peu de prudence
quand on s'adresse aux États-Unis parce
que les États-Unis peuvent être faibles
ils peuvent être avoir des prêts
matériels ils ont des élections dans
quatre semaines ou 5
tout ça peut jouer mais c'est quand même
les États-Unis et quand on s'affront
directement aux États-Unis sur après
aussi vital pour eux que les prix du
pétrole la guerre contre la contre la
guerre de l'Ukraine et de la Russie
quand même il peut y avoir des
conséquences qui sont pas forcément
directs nous on pense toujours c'est les
baisses des armes et ça peut être des
conséquences indirectes ça peut être des
coûts plus tendus
un président américain qui dit de son
allié historique il y aura conséquence
moi j'ai peu entendu ça qui est le plus
à perdre Bruno
bah écoute oui moi j'aurais plutôt
tendance à dire aussi quand même
l'Arabie Saoudite mais enfin pour Joe
Biden si on reprend l'ensemble de la
séquence
c'est pas terrible non plus c'est un peu
rude quand même pour lui il a dit
d'abord pendant sa campagne
ce type là il parlait de moi ben Salman
est un paria l'Arabie Saoudite est un
régime Paris en fait il a eu des mots
extrêmement durs il le paye peut-être
d'ailleurs un peu aujourd'hui
visiblement ça n'est pas passé il est
donc allé à contre-cœur vraiment à
contre-coeur pour des raisons évidemment
gaz pétrole des raisons stratégiques il
est donc allé à jeda début juillet il a
même fait le fameux fils dump voilà
je sais pas comment on dit en français
enfin bref ils ont fait comme ça et ça a
été beaucoup commenté et là aussi ça
devait pas être de getter de cœur il
pensait quand même parce que c'est le
président des États-Unis encore obtenu
une forme d'engagement de l'Arabie
saoudite à faire en sorte que
effectivement ils ouvrent les vannes
elles fanent en sorte que voilà que le
pétrole coule et que le prix soit soit
pas trop élevé et
aux États-Unis donc on voit bien que
tous ces dossiers mais bon c'est
déséquilibre fragiles et et pour les uns
et pour les autres et donc d'avoir des
positions aussi tranchées c'est quand
même assez spectaculaire et puis alors
on verra bien effectivement comme
desiades si c'est un tournant une crise
passion un moment de tension mais quand
même depuis 1945 ça faisait partie quand
même d'un des à comment dire la des
fondamentaux mondiale largement
consolidé Donald Trump pendant son
souvenir depuis 1945
quand le président des États-Unis avec
le roi d'Arabie saoudite à l'époque
enfin le pacte entre les deux c'était
les États-Unis sur votre sécurité et
vous vous assurez notre
approvisionnement en pétrole alors ce
qui est un peu changé aujourd'hui c'est
que les États-Unis ont moins besoin
quand même en quantité du pétrole
saoudien mais en fait
voilà et là ils ont effectivement ils
ont besoin d'un prix mais c'était quand
même un espèce de pacte qui avait
perduré malgré les crises etc depuis
1945 donc si ça est en train de bouger
ce sera une autre conséquence
de la guerre en Ukraine
et si on commençait autre sujet à sortir
de la politique du pire en Ukraine le
Kremlin dissattendre à ce que redget
propose une médiation à Vladimir poutil
les deux hommes se rencontrent demain
jeudi à au Kazakhstan Vladimir Poutine
peut-il avoir intérêt à trouver une
porte de sortie il y a de comment
interpréter vous cette déclaration parce
qu'elle vient du Kremlin qui évoque la
médiation turque c'est un peu nouveau
quand même je sais pas il y a beaucoup
de gens qui se proposent en ce moment
Erdogan qui joue assez bien son jeu
j'allais dire entre deux chaises les
émiratis avec la visite dont on parlait
donc il y a clairement je pense enfin
il y a clairement de part et d'autre la
question de comment on gagne la guerre
les opinions publiques elles pas de
gagner la guerre ok mais ça veut dire
quoi de gagner la guerre ça veut dire
quoi pour l'Ukraine de gagner la guerre
ça veut dire quoi pour la Russie de
gagner la guerre donc ça c'est une
question qui est vraiment posée et puis
on voit que même si on n'est pas dans un
scénario nucléaire qui évoqué par les
uns et les autres mais on voit que
l'escalade peut vite déraper dans tous
les conflits on sait comment on rentre
on sait pas comment on sort et on espère
qu'on sortira pas tous cramé donc on
voit que tout le monde essaye de trouver
des portes et je pense qu'en Russie il y
a eu aussi les révélations dans la
presse américaine d'un face-à-face qui
aurait été tendu entre Poutine et un de
ses proches sur la conduite de la guerre
on voit des changements au niveau de
l'état-major on voit des stratégies qui
changent du jour au lendemain d'un seul
coup on sort les missiles alors qu'on
les avait pas sortis pendant six mois
pourquoi on les avait sortis pendant 6
mois d'un seul coup on bombarde
massivement pourquoi ils ont pas
bombardé même massivement plus tôt donc
il y a des tas de choses qui collent pas
et donc dans cette ambiance un peu
cataclysmique ou des tas de choses ne
collent pas on voit les opinions
européenne qui faiblissent c'est clair
ça quand est-ce qu'on gagne la guerre et
puis c'est combien de temps ça va durer
et puis les Américains vont rentrer en
élection ça se peut ça va tout changer
donc tout ça ça peut être un moment ou
un espèce d'épuisement peut ouvrir la
porte et le problème c'est que la
question
ukrainienne reste posée c'est encore une
fois on revient comment on sort de la
guerre c'est si c'est pour dire on cède
le Dombas on cède la Crimée on accepte
le fait accompli ça va être compliqué à
vendre Ukrainiens si c'est pour dire aux
Russes il faut changer de régime il faut
que le régime change ça est très
compliqué à dire à Vladimir Poutine donc
c'est c'est là que je je vois pas encore
les termes le territoire d'un compromis
possible quel que peut proposer
justement j'étais hyper douanes qui déjà
intervenu et avec succès comme médiateur
dans le conflit oui alors d'abord voilà
clairement il y a son intérêt personnel
à lui parce que il a quand même plutôt
très bien joué sa carte depuis le début
ça a été le seul médiateur qui a eu des
résultats
un peu concret efficace notamment sur de
l'accord sur les céréales d'autres comme
Emmanuel Macron ont un peu tenté alors
non pas de jouer les médiateurs mais on
garde le lien avec Vladimir Poutine on
lui parle etc tout en étant au côté de
l'Ukraine
erdon il l'a fait sans complexe
il n'a pas appliqué des sanctions
internationales contre la Russie en même
temps il a fourni des équipements
militaires notamment des drones à
l'Ukraine donc il est en bonne position
après effectivement on en revient au
terme de la médiation parce que en gros
effectivement comment gagner la guerre
bon il y a quand même soit une solution
militaire soit une solution politique
lui il pousse avec cette tentative de
médiation pour une solution politique
mais encore faut-il s'entendre sur les
termes de la discussion le président
Macron il y a quelques minutes vient de
dire aussi d'appeler Vladimir Poutine à
la table des négociations mais on
négocie sur quoi alors clairement côté
russe on négocie sur le fait que
l'annexion des des fameux territoires et
la Crimée bien sûr tout ça est enterré
et à partir partir de là on négociait
en plus et les Ukrainiens non c'est pas
du tout d'abord on récupère notre
intégrité territoriale et puis après on
dit oui vous voyez que les termes de la
de la négociation pour le moment sont
compliquées avec la leur compte
contre-offensive qui sont pour l'instant
assez réussi eux penchent plutôt pour
l'instant pour la solution militaire
pour dégager les Russes mais la seule
limite à ça c'est que la solution
militaire dépend de la cohésion
euro-américaine qui livre les armes qui
livrent l'argent qui livre tout suffit
que ça ça se faiblisse et le rapport de
force devient complexe bah là avec la
séquence des missiles c'est pas quand
même en train d'insister c'est plutôt
une accélération encore de des
livraisons d'armes y compris française
et justement à les ukrainien eux
continuent de réclamer des arbres à la
France notamment que certains accusent
de livrer trop peu voyez le message
d'amour qu'adresse les Ukrainiens
[Musique]
je t'aime
oui je t'aime
[Musique]
je suis
je
faisais je viens
[Musique]
voilà il faut une fois tous leurs démons
là démonstration leur capacité à
communiquer auprès des opinions
publiques Z je vous vois faire la
grimace c'est de mauvais goût je sais
pas franchement je sais pas d'abord je
sais pas des très bien d'où ça vient ce
truc qu'est-ce que c'est officiel est-ce
que c'est pas officiel ça circule c'est
oui mais le problème d'internet c'est
que tout ce qui circule devient officiel
ou pas je sais pas je pense que
Gainsbourg sur la guerre tout ça bon je
suis pas si j'étais publicitaire je suis
pas fasciné mais encore une fois je veux
dire ça pose la question de la cohérence
des alliés et ça pose la question
excusez-moi du mot que la guerre le
bordel général que cette guerre est en
train de créer et de la pression qui
commence à monter des uns et des y
compris en Chine y compris en Inde dans
les Emirats ailleurs avec ça comment ça
monter pour dire trouver une solution
avant que cette chose nous échappe et
c'est là je pense on est à ce point
précis avant que cette chose nous
échappe Bruno oui alors sur la vidéo
effectivement on peut discuter le bon
goût alors après vous disais un message
d'amour mais vous voyez à la fin un
message d'amour exigeant quand même
beaucoup mais ils veulent des preuves
d'amour de nouvelles preuves d'amour
rapidement et efficacement voilà merci
Bruno Darroux merci yadimam c'était ton
va plus loin restez avec nous on se
retrouve dans moins de 5 minutes pour un
nouveau journal